we're here with the master chef tim
dillon yeah we're doing uh
tim dillon and dan carney make eggs the
last time dan carney made eggs he almost
got thrown out of my house
but we're making good eggs right now
just like my hair is dope as and
this kids is not and this time we're not
gonna it up we're not gonna it
up you got landlakes and this is not
a cultural appropriation issue you got
brown eggs extra large brown eggs
they're good i don't know why they're
good
but i like everything that is non-white
eggs are one of the hardest things to
cook right
ella brennan in new orleans who owns
commander's palace she
she invented commanders you know a style
of she was on the forefront of that
style of cooking they have in new
orleans which is creole which mixes
french
and haitian brandon's restaurant which
has amazing eggs and what's celebrating
doing now
she's dead well there we go the reason
the damn can't make eggs because dan
can't make anything
i use this olive oil it comes from
a great family of culinary people what
did your mom say
my mom once told me that flavor is
overrated can you tell people that the
salmon we got
yeah so this is this is uh from a town
called
veins and dan's foot it's literally
disgusting all right keep going i'm not
gonna apologize for my
for my vascularness how how did you get
good at whisking these eggs i told you
by jerking off
people anyone that has a penis
correct and and not only men have penis
yeah a little pepper in there
a little bit of salt salt wooden spoons
and spatulas like that that's what we
got spanked with as kids is that true
yes and she would say don't make me get
the wooden spoon wow
my car's just getting me with their
hands this is very important
because you want to keep stirring you
want to start consistently
you just throw two whole slices of
cheese in there you know i don't break
them up because the thing is if you
break them up the cheese just kind of
evaporates into the egg and you don't
you just want to push them around you
see why i'm pushing the eggs around
see when you push them around like this
they just become really light and fluffy
you don't really
i'm not getting in there to break the
egg at all no this is very different
than what they ended what dan did was
and dan almost got himself he almost got
himself a ticket out of here i did
almost i had to get my car so angry i
mean truly look at those scrambled eggs
look at how seductive they are that's
what scrambled eggs are that's that's
what america is
you understand so dan is a piece of
when you take the locks put them on the
side of the plate now that's pretty as
because it has the um
it has the dill right and the dill kind
of gives it that
kind of greenness knows what the deal is
it knows jesus christ and with a little
pepper on top nothing crazy
just a little pepper um
and that's it i mean these are let's get
a look at this that's breakfast and that
is pretty amazing it's very
different
from what dan carney did dan is a pure
oil white trash and i'm trying to teach
him how to live like a human being
soon we'll be out of this airbnb and
back to living on the street
thank you guys